цього тижня моя гостя Джуліана Сміт
посолка США в альянсі оскільки війна
триває чи підштовхне НАТО Україну до
переговорів з Росією
Ми не хочемо адаптувати умови на яких
українці сядуть за стіл переговорів вони
самі мають визначити на яких умовах вони
готові та Хочуть вести переговори
що це говорить нам про НАТО чому
президент бадмін вважає що питання
постачання зброї може розвалити Альянс і
незважаючи на те що Україна веде всі
бойові дії хіба захід подобається йому
це чи ні не перебуває останні війни з
Росією
[музика]
Джуліана Сміт Ласкаво просимо в конфлікт
Zone Дякую
всі розмови про єдність НАТО дискусія
щодо відправки танків леопарда 2 Україні
показала значні розбіжності між
країнами-членами Альянсу Наскільки ці
публічні суперечки на ваш погляд
зашкодили іміджу НАТО в розпал великої
війни на Європейському континенті
пощастило проводити в штаб квартирі НАТО
кожен день і я можу заповнити вас що з
місця де я сиджу те що я бачу щодня є не
що інше як постійна єдність
що від часу у нас бувають розбіжності з
питань пов'язаних із війною в Україні чи
з якихось інших питань НАТО безумовно
ми всі Сідаємо за стіл переговорів зі
своєю історією у нас різна географія
різні погляди ми відчуваємо різний
внутрішній тиск
така що протягом усієї цієї війни
протягом останнього року і навіть в
останні дні ми змогли згуртуватися
ми змогли продемонструвати нашу
рішучість забезпечити Українські збройні
сили всім необхідним для захисту своєї
території і сповнені рішучості
продовжувати Цей курс тому мене зовсім
не хвилює те що сталося останніми днями
тижнями чи місяцями Я вважаю що головна
сторона цього Альянсу полягає в його
здатності долати наші розбіжності Та
незважаючи на них зберігати єдність тому
я відверто кажучи не бачу жодної шкоди я
бачу готовність кількох союзників
виступити та надати додаткову та важливу
допомогу українцям Просто зараз у режимі
реального часу
те що ми бачили Це тижні суперечок
навколо питання про постачання танків у
ключовий момент цієї війни ці тижні
майже напевно коштуватимуть життя чи не
так б це не прикро
ми бачимо що союзники майже щоденно
спілкуються з українським військовим
командуванням щоб насамперед зрозуміти
Які їхні потреби у конкретний момент
ми робимо це з 24 лютого Минулого року
ви знаєте що Сполучені Штати також
очолюють контактну групу з питань
оборони України дещомісяця 50 різних
країн збираються разом і дізнаються
безпосередньо українців про їхні
військові потреби
потім ми порівнюємо ці вимоги з тим що
союзники хочуть їй можуть надати і в
цьому випадку можна говорити про
еволюцію від самого початку йшлося не
про бронетехніку ми почали говорити про
стін гри і джевеліни коли російські
війська стрімко йшли на Київ Влітку ми
багато говорили про боєприпаси ви
пам'ятаєте наскільки гострою була ця
потреба Під час цієї війни в нас були
періоди коли ми говорили і про засоби
берегової оборони Нині ж ми дійсно дуже
сильно зосереджені на бронетехніці й
танках
тому що в розмова з українцями ми дійшли
висновку що маємо забезпечити їм
можливість маневрів
щоб вони могли не тільки захищати свою
територію а й закріпитися для подальшого
успіху припускаючи що буде ще один
Контрнаступ як з їхнього боку так і
можливо наступ з боку росіян
Отже ви маєте рацію Це була низка
розмова
як президент Байден говорив про серйозну
взаємодію яку ми мали не лише з урядом
Німеччини а й з іншими союзниками щоб
побачити що ще ми можемо передати
українцям якнайшвидше то Журнал зараз
поворотний момент для Альянсу
YouTube
про розмову але заклики до передачі цієї
зброї з українського боку з плином
тижнів стають дедалі нагальнішими і була
досить гостра критика позиції Німеччини
Польщі наприклад заявили що озброєння
України для відбиття російської агресії
це не якась вправа з ухвалення рішень
українська кров проливається по
справжньому це ціна вагань щодо поставок
леопардів чи справді членам НАТО
потрібно нагадувати наскільки серйозні
ставки у цій війні
знову ж таки оскільки я щодня си тут
НАТО можу запевнити вас що Всі розуміють
серйозність ситуації люди розуміють
терміновість ми розуміємо наскільки
чудовими є Українські збройні сили
наскільки вони ефективні у віці чи
російській агресії
ми розуміємо нагальній ситуації тому що
ми працюємо тут тиждень за тиждень уже
майже рік запевняючи що ми можемо
підтримувати Україну та надавати їй не
лише безпекову допомогу про яку ми тут
сьогодні говоримо але й терміново
доставити інші форми допомоги
ми розуміємо нагальну потребу поставити
їм гуманітарну допомогу економічну
допомогу і звичайно допомогу для
боротьби з цими атаками на критичну
інфраструктуру України
Ми швидко рухаємося щоб доставити їм
такі речі як пальне генератори та зимове
спорядження тому ми сприймаємо ситуацію
дуже серйозно Ми зустрічаємося буквально
щотижня з приводу війни в Україні на
кожному міністерському рівні на кожному
який ми проводили протягом останнього
року брали участь Наші друзі з України
Тож я можу вас запевнити що ніхто не
сприймає їхні вимоги легковажно особливо
Сполучені Штати які надали майже 27
мільярдів доларів підтримки у сфері
безпеки за останній рік
досить рішуче натякнув на деякі зі
значних труднощів з якими він зіткнувся
намагаючись зберегти єдність НАТО і те
наскільки суперечливим є питання зброї
яку варто надсилати він сказав 21 грудня
в Білому домі що йде про те що ми надамо
Україні матеріальні засоби які
принципово відрізняються від тих які
Туди вже надходять матиме перспективу
розпаду НАТО та розпаду Європейського
Союзу та решта світу це досить
апокаліптично чи не так тож ці суперечки
про те що давати а що не давати Києву
будуть тривати чи не так потенціалом
коштувати більше життів і фактично
знищити
На жаль ця війна змінюється щодня Ми
бачили як росіяни здійснюють усілякі
форми агресії
чи то звичайно атаки які здійснюють їхні
війська чи тоді проти українських
військових сил
Чи це військові злочини та порушення
прав людини свідками яких ми стали в
Україні
читати на критичну інфраструктуру
картинка всередині України
Вона змінювалася майже кожного тижня під
час цього конфлікту
і як наслідок союзники часто сідають за
стіл та обговорюють якнайкраще допомогти
народу України
і головне військовим всередині України
коли Вони захищають свою територію від
російської агресії
знову ж таки я не вважаю консенсус з
проблемою це сила це вимагає праці
збереження єдності означає що ми маємо
постійно спілкуватися це те що ми робимо
тут НАТО і я вважаю що ми це добре
робимо і ми спираємося на історію НАТО
майже 75 років історії роботи над
розбіжностями коли вони випливають на
поверхню тому я впевнена що Альянс буде
єдиним
Я не бачу жодних тріщин у НАТО частково
тому що я думаю що союзники принципово
розуміють що тут поставлено на карту
ми знаємо що українці воюють щоб
захистити свою територію але кожен
союзник Тут також цінує те що вони
захищають цінності які ми всі цінуємо і
з цієї причини альтернативи просто немає
ми підтримуватимемо Україну стільки
скільки буде потрібно і я не бачу щоб ця
позиція так чи інакше змінилася
і все ж ваш президент вважав за
необхідне підкреслити перспективу того
що і НАТО і ЄС можуть розпастися через
питання про те яку зброю відправляти
якби ви сказали мені ще кілька років
тому що Європейський союз надаватиме
підтримку летальної зброї і українському
народу чи допомогу в сфері безпеки я не
думаю що я б вам повірила Це був
головний важливий поворотний момент для
Європейського Союзу
крім того на додачу до зміни своєї
позиції щодо надання безпекової допомоги
Ми також маємо випадок коли ці два
органи які розташовані в одному місті
тут у Брюсселі не завжди об'єднуються
Але у випадку з Україною ми маємо
ситуацію коли ієс і НАТО об'єднали
зусилля щоб зосередитися на підтримці
України
що це означає на практиці на практиці це
означає що щоразу коли міністри
закордонних справ країн членів НАТО
міністри оборо починають глави держав
НАТО зустрічаються тут у Брюсселі чи в
іншому місці ми маємо присутність
Європейського Союзу вони з нами за
столом вони з нами за столом тому що ми
бачимо додаткову цінність у передачі
меседжів не лише українському народу і
очевидно також в Москві а й у передачі
меседжів світовій спільноті при рівень
єдності який ми бачимо
досить примітно як Ці дві організації
змогли розширити свою співпрацю у
зв'язку з війною що триває в Україні
Отже частина ЄС НАТО насправді є чудовою
історією поглибленої співпраці Я думаю
що ми можемо розвивати її в майбутньому
говорить про свої стратегічні цілі вони
поки що здавалися досить розпливчастими
Ви самі сказали Ми зробимо все що
потрібно ми будемо дотримуватися певного
курсу Росія не повинна виграти Україна
не повинна програти Україна повинна бути
в змозі себе захистити Чи є у вас
бачення того яких цілей повинна досягти
в цій війні Україна поза тим
узагальненими та туманними коментарями
по-перше повертаючись назад Я вважаю що
стратегічні цілі всередині НАТО
кришталевої ясні у
публічних заявах деклараціях комунікація
самітів пресрелізах і в усьому іншому Ми
дуже чітко заявили що ми зосереджені
перш за все на зміцненні східного флангу
НАТО та забезпечені безпеки наших
союзників по НАТО
по-друге ми продовжуватимемо надавати
індивідуальну підтримку народу України
та українським збройним силам
по-третє колективно ми будемо
продовжувати чинити тиск на Москву щодо
вашого запитання про результати цієї
війни проте куди Вона рухається до якого
стра напрямку Ми прагнемо давайте не
будемо забувати що це війна яку українці
ведуть проти російської агресії
український уряд президент Зеленський і
його оточення мають самі визначити Куди
вони йдуть Які їхні плани яка їхня
стратегія
ми тут щоб їх підтримати НАТО не бере
безпосередньої участі це не конфлікт між
НАТО і Росією це війна яка йде з Москви
від президента Путіна проти України і
Україні зрештою доведеться ухвалити
власні суверені рішення щодо того як
вона хоче захистити свою територію
виштовхнути Росію та припинити цю війну
але найважливішим гравцем у всьому цьому
очевидно є президент Путін саме він
розпочав війну 24 лютого Минулого року
він той хто може покласти край війні і
ми зробимо все можливе щоб змінити його
стратегічний розрахунок щоб спробувати
спонукати його рухатися в іншому
напрямку та вивести російські одна з
України але відповідь на запитання яке
ви ставите мають дати українці
війни але й не просто спостерігачі ви
тренуєте ви постачаєте ви вкладаєте
величезні Суми грошей щоб отримати
країну на плаву ви надаєте розвідання
консультуєте плани війни ви робите все
крім того щоб самі натиснути на курок
хіба від мінність між бійцем і
постачальником не стає досить
академічною
летальної підтримки
немає жодної присутності на землі військ
НАТО в Україні немає
але окремі союзники прийшли на допомогу
Україні коли вона захищає свою територію
від російської агресії
Я вважаю що це важлива відмінність Росія
дуже сильно намагається поширити інший
контрнаратив який є неправдивим
вона часто намагається стверджувати що
НАТО безпосередньо задіяна але це не так
ми допомагаємо українським військовим
захищати свою територію
чи боїться НАТО Росії Я запитую тому що
чуючи постійні ядерні погрози Москви і
фактично ходячи навшпиньки навколо
Путіна чи не повівся Альянс на ядерний
шантаж
Я думаю що Альянс чітко дав зрозуміти що
ми вважаємо це бряценя ядерною зброєю
Росії дуже тривожним окремі країни такі
як Сполучені Штати Ви чули про це від
адміністрації байдена
дуже чітко дали зрозуміти росіянам
якщо вони вирішать скористатися своїм
ядерним арсеналом це призведе до
катастрофічних наслідків наразі з того
боку багато порожніх погроз ми не бачимо
доказів того що Росія готується
використати свій ядерний Арсенал у
будь-якому вигляді чи формі Але знову ж
таки союзники понату дуже чітко заявили
що Росія зіткнеться з серйозними
наслідками якщо вирішить це зробити
чим закінчиться ця війна Чи згодні ви з
тим що перспектива великої військової
Перемоги є малоймовірною
Я думаю що зараз ми зосереджені на тому
щоб поставити українців у найкраще
можливе положення для ситуації коли
можуть відбутися потенційні переговори
ми не знаємо коли це станеться я думаю
що багато хто з нас припускає Що в
якийсь момент українці та росіяни
прийдуть до необхідності повернутися за
стіл переговорів і коли це станеться Ми
хочемо бути впевнені що Україна
перебуває в максимально сильній позиції
я не можу робити жодних прогнозів щодо
результату цієї війни Ніхто з нас не
може Ніхто з нас не знає про що думає
Путін чи збирається він виводити свої
війська і коли я скажу що ми очікуємо що
Україна переможе і робимо все можливе
щоб це сталося
чи буде НАТО підштовхувати Україну до
переговорів навіть якщо вона не буде до
них готова
Ukraine це рішення має ухвалювати
Україна Ми не хочемо диктувати на яких
українці сядуть за стіл переговорів
вони самі мають визначити на яких умовах
вони готові та Хочуть вести переговори
і ми залишимо це в їхніх руках це їхнє
суверенне рішення
пані Жуляни Сміт Велике спасибі за
участь у конфлікт дякую
[музика]